emmanuel macron fait-il déjà campagne
avec le carnet de chèques de la france
est notre débat d'actualité et
j'accueille françois patriat vent soit
un soir bienvenue vous êtes sénateur de
la côte-d'or président du groupe
rassemblement démocrate progressiste et
indépendants au sénat la majorité
présidentielle jean-raymond hugonnet
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue sénateurs et
l'air l'est républicain de l'essonne
j'accueille également stéphane louis
leers bonsoir bienvenue économise vous
publiez crise économique 2020 vers un
nouveau monde avec henri sterdyniak
c'est aux éditions economica et matthieu
croissandeau à mes côtés les
surveillances des lundis et mercredis
bonsoir bienvenue mathieu heureux de
vous retrouver évidemment
comme chaque soir où vous êtes présents
dans ce sens public c'est du bonheur le
budget pour commencer ensuite on
élargira évidemment à toutes ces
critiques concentrées contre le
président de république le jeu reprend
ce qui était dans le sujet à l'instant
le haut conseil des finances publiques
par la voix de pierre moscovici qui se
dit incapable de rendre un avis
pleinement éclairer ce que c'est un
budget à tron françois patriat d'abord
ce qu'a dit esprit n'a pas été rapporté
dans la presse ce qu'a dit pierre
moscovici il n'a jamais qualifié ce
budget d'un sincère thème tout ça mais
c'est la tacc ma sincérité il a dit
manque deux éléments importants dans le
budget qui arriveront dans la loi de
finances forme d'amendements le
financement de la pac de croissance à de
la relance économique
et puis celui du contrat d'engagement
pour les jeunes de 20 ans qui n'ont
encore pas finalisées n'ont pas encore
finalisé le financement sera finalisé
dans les jours qui viennent et
conformément à la loi constitutionnelle
cet amendement passeront dans la
première lecture en loi de finances ici
oui mais ça donne un sentiment de flou
non non ça donne le sentiment que il ya
un engagement qui est prêt pour les
jeunes et les nécessaires aujourd'hui
parce qu'on viendra tout à l'heure sur
le carnet de chèques de la campagne si
vous voulez bien sûr qu'il reviendra
je pense que la la c'est un engagement
qui est pris le goût veut le chef de
l'état a dit qu'il gouvernerait jusqu'au
bout qu'il réformerait jusqu'au bout
qu'il répondrait aux attentes jusqu'au
bout là il s'agit dit il s'agit pour les
jeunes de quelque chose d'important et
réclamé par l'opposition d'ailleurs par
ailleurs aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche
1 sur tout et surtout à gauche en
particulier et pour le pacte de relance
à nouvelle relance de croissance là
c'est nécessaire pour préparer la future
croissance de demain et l'avenir voilà
jean louis bonnet ce fonds je reprends
le mot est ce que ça vous inquiète ah
c'est autre chose qui m'inquiète ce
qu'il ya deux niveaux si vous voulez y
est les mécaniques de construction
budgétaire et françois patriat elle
vient de rappeler alors là après on peut
jouer sur les mots ce qui m'inquiète
plutôt c'est qu'on a un président de la
république qui s'est toujours affichée
comme un réformateur il n'a pas réformé
grand chose et surtout pas le budget
puisque de façon constante il est en
déficit avec une dette abyssale et
malgré cela j'entends le ministre bruno
le maire qui parlait de responsabilité
et de sérieux c'est ça qui me fait peur
c'est qu'on se moque des français parce
qu'encore une fois on leur parle du
budget
passe comme une lettre à la poste oui
c'est un débat de spécialistes mais dans
l'affairé d'ailleurs j'ai un peu hésité
à démarrer je vais très honnête avec
vous sur l'analyse du projet financé
budget parce que c'est vrai que ça passe
souvent et on est moi je suis pas là
pour avoir une critique frontale chacun
est dans son rôle avec la petite phrase
qui va bien - c'est pas ça qui m
inquiète les gens que je croise dans mon
département et dans tous les
départements
qu'est ce qu'il pense du budget français
qu'est ce qu'il pense ils pensent que
l'argent coule à flots quoi qu'il en
coûte et ils n'ont absolument pas
absolument il ya encore pas si longtemps
des économistes renommés disait oui la
dette on va à l'effacer mais sincèrement
de qui se moque t'on on est devant
quelque chose qui est vraiment complexe
difficile et pas facile à approcher mais
il faut dire la vérité on ment aux
français effectivement le mot
insincérité n'a pas été prononcé
rappelons nous qu'en 2017 manuel valls
dernier budget de françois hollande a
essayé de nous faire croire que le
budget est sincère alors qu'il est s'est
avéré après qu'il est est insincère
l'insincérité budgétés en tant qu'élu
les est-ce que vous l'employez vont ce
mot sur ce budget non sincérité mais non
1 parce que je ne suis pas dans la
commission finances voilà et d'une donc
on va regarder en ce qui me concerne
c'est je vais particulièrement attentif
au crédit sur l'audiovisuel public parce
qu'on nous mène en bateau depuis cinq
ans et c'est un des échecs des manuels
macron sur l'audiovisuel public mais ce
que je souhaite c'est que l'on explique
aux français réellement la situation
dans laquelle on trouve le pays voilà
bien compris stéphanie muller ce manque
un élément important pour analyser ce
budget c'est quoi c'est la croissance
oui mais enfin elle a été quand même
anticipé puisque il imagine le
gouvernement français l'imaginent
l'année prochaine à 1 4% donc au final
on va se retrouver en 2022 avec une
croissance à 4% et un déficit aussi de
4% même chose pour 2021 la croissance
est estimé à 6,25 et on enregistre la
liste 6,25 on aura entre 6 et 6 25,6 et
demi vu les acquis de croissance qu'on a
depuis le début de l'année on peut dire
que sauf choc sur le quatrième trimestre
on est vers vers cette tendance là pour
autant on a on va avoir un déficit
public de 8,4 pour cent donc on est dans
une situation complètement ubuesque où
on a de la croissance mais pour avoir de
la croissance on continue le déficit
c'est à dire que l'année dernière on
pouvait imaginer en pleine crise
sanitaire avoir effectivement une
croissance qui qui dégringolait à moins
8 alors oui bien sûr on faisait bien sûr
il fallait 2 2 un soutien budgétaire
mais là on est en situation de
croissance et il n'y a pas uniquement le
gouvernement
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat premier numéro d' allons plus loin
je suis ravi de vous retrouver nous
sommes ensemble pendant deux heures deux
heures en direct avec vous on va prendre
le temps d'analyser de questionner
toutes les ce budget a été accueilli en
rejoint quentin quentin calme mais qui
est en direct de la salle des des
conférences faites nous un bilan a
résumé quentin oui on a compris ici au
sénat que les débats étaient vifs
notamment parce que l'actualité sur ce
budget elle s'est passé au sénat
aujourd'hui on l'a vu dans le sujet de
fabien hecquet a bien moscovici qui
était auditionné ce matin par la
commission des finances est en ce moment
même ce son est bien bruno le maire et
olivier du soft donc les ministres de
l'économie et des budgets qui sont
auditionnés juste à côté du studio de
sens public adhère à quelques encablures
et que maître du sud de public sénat et
donc dans les couloirs du sénat on
entend qu'il ya deux types te reproche
qui reviennent à notamment sur ces trous
dans le budget qu'on évoque depuis le
but de l'émission est bien pour les
sénateurs ça pose une question d'ordre
démocratique écoutait le chef de file
des sénateurs centristes is you sénat
qui en plus c'est la cour des comptes
qui le dénonce d'abord j'ai tendance à
faire confiance à la cour des comptes
donc on travaille ou le savait depuis
déjà des mois
et même beaucoup de moi dans des
conditions qui sont difficiles dans
l'urgence on n'a pas le temps de d'aller
au fond des choses on va voir ce budget
les deux budgets d'ailleurs plfss et plf
fort et qu'on ait la capacité à avoir un
dialogue avec le gouvernement à voir les
vrais chiffres savoir quelles sont les
grandes orientations je crois que c'est
un voeu pieux parce qu'avec les
présidentielle qui s'annonce je pense
que avoir le rythme des dépenses on
n'est pas près de voir le bout de ce
budget voilà et au delà de cette méthode
thomas on s'étonne aussi de l'importance
des trous des trous dans ce budget car
ce ne sont pas des mesures anodines ou
circonstancielle mais bien des mesures à
long terme donc ce plan d'investissement
de 30 milliards sur plusieurs années et
ce nouveau revenu d'engagement pour les
jeunes dont on ne connaît pas encore le
détail mais qui pourrait représenter
deux milliards
écoutez l'agacement du président
socialiste de la commission des finances
du sénat on est sur des mesures quand
une vocation à être pérennisées en tout
cas pour celles pour l'engagement des
jeunes très clairement
oui c'est 2 milliards d'euros mais qui
vont être pérennisé voyez ce que je
viens donc sont des travaux
préparatoires qu'il faut faire avant la
présentation du budget même chose pour
le plan d'investissement qui est quand
même dans le tome c'est quand même
curieux qu'on n'est pas des le budget au
moins le coût pour 2022 voilà dernier
élément que je voulais vous signaler
thomas ion viens de l'entendre avec la
prise de parole de claude raynal mais
c'est que beaucoup de sénateurs évoque
et bien l'échéance présidentielle
ils sont pas naïfs 1 ils voient se
profiler l'élection présidentielle donc
pour eux ils le disent c'est bien et
bien en vue de cette élection et que ce
budget a été présenté aujourd'hui merci
quentin pour cette analyse effectivement
on fait avancer ce débat vers ce thème
de la campagne présidentielle même si
évidemment emmanuel macron n'est pas
officiellement candidat je vous propose
un florilège de deux d'annonce mesures
qui ont été faites par le chef de l'état
dans lors de ces dernières semaines
regarder en 2022 le ministère de
l'intérieur verra ainsi son budget
augmenter de près de 1,5 milliard
d'euros dont 500 millions d'euros pour
la mise en oeuvre des premières mesures
du beauvau de la sécurité nous allons
créer le système de l'assurance récolte
français et il va reposer sur trois
piliers
d'abord la solidarité nationale et donc
nous avons décidé qu'on mettra 600
millions d'euros par an en moyenne pour
permettre de financer le système c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement portera avant
la fin de l'année un projet
visant à inscrire dans le marbre de nos
lois la reconnaissance et la réparation
à l'égard des harkis c'est pourquoi nous
doublerons dès janvier le crédit d'impôt
pour la formation de tous les dirigeants
d'entreprise de moins de 10 salariés ce
doublement et
alors là on n'a pas mis tous
évidemment quelques autres ces faits
similaires c'est ce que vous diriez que
c'est un budget de campagne électorale
mais bien évidemment vous sentez il est
totalement inédit parce que pour une
fois on fait le pacte de stabilité a été
suspendu jusqu'à mi jusqu'à fin 2022
alors le pacte de stabilité vous savez
c'est bruxelles qui nous impose à
maintenir une certaine forme de rigueur
budgétaire donc là on fait plus cette
épée de damoclès jusqu'à fin de jusqu'à
fin de l'année prochaine donc bah c'est
normal que le gouvernement en profite et
ils profitent largement en annonçant dès
des mesures à venir qui pourraient
intéresser l'électorat est ce que je
pense que n'importe quel président fait
autant ça c'est une c'était important de
laisser aller jusque là et effectivement
mathieu si on regarde un peu dans le
rétroviseur c'est pas nouveau non alors
c'est pas la première fois c'est un
grand classique des campagnes
électorales tenez si je vous dis à
chaque sortie ou presque et il sort
beaucoup de prison d'un public et le
geste généreux la politique des cadeaux
tend à devenir une habitude chaque
dimanche à chaque occasion des milliards
sont distribués parmi toutes les
déviations institutionnelles auxquelles
nous assistons celle ci est l'une des
plus graves qui aient de saint claude
labbé on est en décembre 1980 il est à
la tête du groupe rpr à l'assemblée il
vise valéry giscard d'estaing à qui on
reproche des gestes pour les
agriculteurs pour les veuves pour les
pme je vous en donne une autre depuis le
début de l'année il a déjà dépensé en
cadeaux divers ce que la croissance ne
lui a pas encore donné cela représente
similaire de dépenses en plus là nous
sommes en mai 2016 c'est françois fillon
à propos de françois hollande la droite
à l'époque dénonce une politique du
chéquier ça vous dit quelque chose c'est
exactement les mêmes arguments et promet
de mettre en place un compteur pour
lister les cadeaux et les chèques remis
à chaque catégorie à une catégorie
sociale en vue de de l'élection le
compteur il va peut-être sortir là dans
l'est dans les prochains jours on sait
jamais est ce que c'est un argument de
campagne pertinents non c'est un peu
bidon pour trois raisons d'abord parce
que les français ne se soucie guère de
l'orthodoxie budgétaire et le contexte
en plus bruxellois qui nous y autorise
on peut s'en désoler où on peut en rire
mais en tout cas les déficit public la
dette ça passionne pas les français sauf
quand ça se traduit en hausse d'impôts
ce que l'exécutif bien évidemment se
refuse à engager ensuite parce que
l'argument il est d'une certaine façon
réversible et on en a parlé aussi tout à
l'heure les mêmes qui critiquent
l'exécutif d'être trop dépensier eux
font passer la douane magique sur leurs
propositions et promettent monts et
merveilles et puis ensuite parce que
parfois même quand l'exécutif veut pas
dépenser une opposition est un peu
pousse au crime souvenez vous on est le
4 juillet 99 les la croissance est
revenue et jacques chirac
tance lionel jospin en disant qu'à une
cagnotte et qu' il faut rendre aux
français le fruit de la cagnotte alors
que on a quand même un budget en déficit
et une dette à 60% et lionel jospin se
retrouvent contraints et forcés de faire
des cadeaux malgré lui faire des cadeaux
ou est ce que
c'est ce que c'est bon pour ça fait rire
c'est là que ça devient très amusant
parce que la réponse est non c'est bien
simple tous les tous les tous ceux qui
tenait les cordons de la bourse et qui
se sont présentés ont été battus depuis
40 ans on peut regarder un 1980 jusqu'à
il est battu 88 c'est chirac quitter les
cordons de la bourse à matignon il est
battu 95 balladur il est battu et on
peut continuer comme ça 2007 villepin il
peut pas y aller 2012 sarkozy il est
battu et je vous raconte pas françois
hollande derrière donc c'est quelque
chose quand même que ça incite tous les
bilans qu'ils soient généreux ou non
tout ce qui n'a pas été fait vous est
reproché tout ce qui a été fait et c'est
oublié et c'est visiblement une règle
d'or doit oublier l'essentiel et je
crois moi je partage qui vient d'être
dit mes dents dans leur citation
historique vous auriez plus un élément
qui est révélateur sur ce que c'est que
le budget le budget 2010 8
olivier du soft alors député socialiste
votre contre la confiance à edouard
philippe et votre contre le budget six
jours après 6 il est nommé au
gouvernement il vient défendre ici moi
c'est le premier j'étais élu en 2017 je
le vois débarquer plutôt sympathique le
malheureux pour défendre le budget
contre lequel il a voté six jours avant
ça ça vous résume le total est encore
une fois je mets là dedans droite gauche
a on va pas commencer à faire parce que
les uns ont tellement changé qu'on sait
plus où il va là ça lui a valu
d'ailleurs d'être chassé du parti
socialiste olivier du soft donc ça c'est
révélateur
aujourd'hui de ce qui se joue là devant
mais c'est par satellite est une forme
d'irresponsabilité face aux enjeux d'un
budget est bien en compte dans votre
réponse mais surtout que l'état soit là
où il doit être
et qu'il arrête d'être là où il ne doit
pas être aujourd'hui en termes
d'entreprise qu'on simplifie
il toque mans nous allons rencontrer des
hommes et des femmes qui dans une forme
de résistance continue à se battre pour
préserver un mode d'agriculture des
traditions à savoir faire alimentaire
qui nous permettent de nous protéger de
la malbouffe
[Musique]
très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle émission bonjour chez
vous c'est votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité qui vous concernent des
débats des reportages et bien sûr toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat premier numéro d' allons plus loin
je suis ravi de vous retrouver nous
sommes ensemble pendant deux heures deux
heures en direct avec vous on va prendre
le temps d'analyser de questionner toute
l'actualité politique parlementaire mais
aussi international vous allez le voir
je
vous
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro
de votre émission les matins du sénat où
vous allez être plongés au coeur des
travaux de la haute assemblée
[Musique]
vous
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
manger c'est voter vous l'avez compris
nous sommes sur la côte normande à re
manche à l'emplacement même où les
alliés débarquaient en 1944 pour sauver
le monde libre de la barbarie nazie
justement nous allons rencontrer des
hommes et des femmes qui dans une forme
de résistance continue à se battre pour
préserver un mode d'agriculture des
traditions à savoir faire alimentaire
qui nous permettent de nous protéger de
la malbouffe
[Musique]
très heureuse de vous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle émission bonjour chez
vous c'est votre rendez vous quotidien
avec l'actualité qui vous concernent des
débats des reportages et bien sûr toute
l'actualité politique et parlementaire
[Musique]
assurer
les moyens de l'état ont été mis en très
grande partie n'est en priorité sur le
soutien à l'activité économique et sur
la crise sanitaire mais le reste de
l'activité politique a été congés et là
il ya une forme de rattrapage où 181
personnes sans emploi total on retrouve
l emporte depuis les six oui mais
emmanuel macron va voir un peu toutes
les corporations tous les dossiers qui
n'ont pas été traités et puis par
ailleurs il occupe le terrain parce
qu'il sait bien que s'il est partout et
belle opposition et ne pas moi je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur cette
question dépense mon carnet de chèques
d'un côté critiques de la droite et puis
investissement c'est vraiment on a
presque le sentiment que emmanuel macron
a préempté cet argument oui c'est quand
je dirige investit pour l'avenir
l'origine c'est effectivement c'est une
série d'objectifs faut savoir qu'en
france on fait c'est le premier budget
qui rognait quand ça va mal ça reste
quand même l'investissement ainsi on a
plutôt tendance à aller vers les
dépenses de fonctionnement et les
dépenses sociales que les dépenses
investissements alors maintenant son âme
l'europe nous a donné une espèce de
nouvelles ambitions avec ce plan de 750
milliards ou on investit dans les
secteurs de demain et ça on en a on en a
véritablement besoin tous les pays
membres ont besoin de se développer sur
la transition écologique le numérique au
niveau français hexagonal en fait on
peut pas faire grand chose on est bien
sûr mais trop petit pour faire
concurrence aux états unis ou à la chine
qu'il faut s'allier à l'union européenne
ne faut pas se tromper de débat la
france si elle peut faire quelque chose
c'est plutôt diminuer ses dépenses
publiques qui reste quand même à 56%
toujours du pin et quand on reste quand
même le pays qui a le les dépenses
publiques les plus élevées et noé nos
recettes eh bien on compte sur la
croissance mais là encore ça reste
encore ça dépend de notre capacité à
faire des réformes en face mais surtout
mais le mandat d' emmanuel macron à
commencer par des baisses d'impôts et
d'ailleurs on est ici même hier soir on
a rappelé que les baisses d'impôt avait
donné comme pouvoir d'achat opa mal de
l'exercice budgétaire aussi hors norme
il ya eu une chance incroyable c'est
qu'il a commencé son mandat avec des
baisses d'impôts massives à on l'avait
sur les ménages sur les entreprises et
après au moment où il fallait en
contrepartie aller vers la baisse des
dépenses 2020 crise sanitaire et là on
ouvre le chéquier tout tout l'europe
voilà paumé pays européens et donc bah
finalement là il en mai faudra peut-être
faire après emmanuel macron ne la
connais pas et n'a jamais pris une
mesure visant à assurer une forme de
rigueur bénéfices sur les étudiants oui
mais on est
patriote mois il avait ramené le déficit
à moins de 3% il est arrivé à 2,9 carson
y était arrivé avant on avait assez
chaud à 8% là on a on a les cités on va
les regarder les chiffres du déficit
mais allez-y continuer maintenant on va
regarder ce qu'ils étaient avant la
crise on était avant la crise on était
arrivé à moins de trois faits qui moi on
est arrivé on a baissé de deux points
les prélèvements obligatoires et on a
baissé les impôts comme personne ne les
a b c le nabour écho beaucoup réformer
le pays contrairement à ce que dit
monsieur venait effectivement donc on là
je viens à la question de la réforme et
de l'investissement effectué elle
m'envoie c'est ce niveau de déficit
public 2,3 c'était 2018 aujourd'hui 8,4
et prévisions pour l'année prochaine 4,8
pour cent ça c'est le déficit qui on
peut regarder la dette la dette on est
en était à 100% du pib en 2010 est on
est à 118 % du pib aujourd'hui dans
votre chronique mathieu tout à l'heure
vous disiez que sous jospin on était à
60% ce que ça donc ça a pratiquement
doublé ça c'était même s'était même dans
les fameux critères de
maastricht poursuit près sûr que qu'on
ait envie de retrouver là
oui je sais bien je sais bien faire ça
permet justement la question du choix de
société ça chauffe ça passionnant
jean-raymond hugonnet c'est celle
peut-être le moment on parle
d'investissements tout cas c'est
l'argument deux de l'exécutif c'est le
moment d'inventer une nouvelle société
de sueur est ce que c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer
malheureusement certaines certaines
personnes ils réfléchissent sans vouloir
faire de pub je n'ai pas d'actions ni
dans sa société d'édition ni avec lui
mais un garçon qui s'appelle david djaïz
c'est drôle parce que là on invite dans
quelques jours donc ça ça nous passionne
là quelqu'un d'extrêmement briand est
pas brillant pour être reluisant mais
brillant parce qu'en profondeur il a
compris il explique comment le modèle
qui a été à son paroxysme sous georges
pompidou commence ce modèle aujourd'hui
ne peut plus fonctionner il faut ré ans
en réinventer un mais quand on réinvente
un modèle ça peut être satisfaisant
intellectuellement la preuve par 4 de ce
qui ne va pas financièrement vous la
comprenez quand vous êtes élu local
quand j'ai été élu maire pour la
première fois en 2001 j'ai compris qu'il
fallait présenter un budget en équilibre
et en fonctionnement recettes et
dépenses et en investissement voilà si
je ne le faisais pas l'état par la voix
du préfet et des services déconcentrés
de l'état me taper dessus et refuser mon
budget donc l'état qui oblige toutes les
communes de france à avoir une gestion
saine si la loi bien heureusement que
c'est la loi la loi mais heureusement
que c'est la loi mais il ne s'applique
pas la même voilà il ne le seul à la
même énergie surtout pas et ils
dépensent sans compter encore une fois
non mais je vais les collectivités
locales s'étonne-t-elle pour payer c'est
toujours aller dans
le faire parce que quand vous dites que
je reviens sur la question
transformation du pays oui je jouais que
vous restiez sur cette île passe comme
ça comme ça françois patriat pourra
répondre est ce que ses dépenses au delà
de la campagne électorale je suis
d'accord avec mathieu mais est ce que
ces dépôts sont potentiellement un
levier pour transformer notre pays je
vous le dis clairement et madame l'a dit
si vous ne faites pas les réformes de
fonctionnement l'investissement n'est
pas le problème dans un ménage si vous
êtes fous vous investissez n'importe
comment vous empruntez vous êtes
surendetté après vous passer à la trappe
c'est le fonctionnement qui pose
problème et c'est là où je revient sur
le fait que l'état est omniprésente dans
des secteurs sur lequel il ne devrait
plus être est en revanche les airs t il
à l'économie aujourd'hui il ya une
mesure économique tous les patrons
grands petits moyens attendent c'est la
baisse des charges sur les salaires il
n'est pas normal aujourd'hui que les
salaires soient tellement chargé en
france c'est tout c'est impossible on en
crève l'économie en crève difficilement
plus de charges écoutez données sur les
salaires il ya plus beaucoup de charge
aujourd'hui élevée sur les motivations à
baisser les charges sociales pour les
salariés ce qui fait un gain de pouvoir
d'achat de l'ordre de 250 euros par an
mais qu'est ce qui changerait la vie ce
qui changerait la vie en france si
demain le travail remplace l assistanat
si les jambes mais j'ai besoin de plus
ce que tu aimes à coups de pied 55
forget plus travaillante ont été
invitées passaient leur étant delà de
l'assurance chômage c'est
inciter les gens à les travailler parce
que tout ce que vous disions dans la rue
mais les gens y viennent pas ils gagnent
autant quand ils restent chez eux que
quand ils ont travaillé ça ça changerait
la vie de l'innovation mais qu'est ce
qu'on attend c'est à l'épée mais à des
seconds fait c'est ce que facebook ça
fait cinq ans mais c'est qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'a fait ce gouvernement avec
la prime pour l'emploi écoutez je
collais les jeunes qui aujourd'hui gagne
plus et je travaille plus vont pas au
chômage parce qu'ils ont la prime pour
l'emploi qui a été doublé on l'a fait on
l'a fait vous l'avez oublié mais oh non
non moi je n'oublie pas je regarde le
résultat est là c'est tout eh ben je
juge sur pied le résultat aujourd'hui
c'est que le chômage des jeunes a baissé
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le plus de jeunes
qui s'investissent c'est que le chômage
est remis à 8% alors que tout on est
revenues maintenant à 2008 1 connaît on
est au début tu débutes sarkozy entre
temps qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec les
crises qu'on a connu on nous prévoyait
des faillites du chômage de masse
aujourd'hui il ya des gars qui a plein
de secteurs qui cherchent à pouvoir
employer qu'il le peut l'employabilité
aujourd'hui il ya plus de gens en
formation chômeurs dit qu'il en avait
avant pour réussir donc ce qui
changerait c'est la valeur travail c'est
là c'est l'innovation je pense que la
france a eu des retards longtemps sur la
recherche l'innovation c'est là qu'on
créera les richesses de domaine et leur
prendre toujours des exemples haillan je
suis toujours étonné par cette
fascination qu'ont les opposants et les
français à les regarder à l'étranger en
suisse on l'a fait avec olaf avec la
vaccination souvenez-vous au début les
allemands les anglais les israéliens
aujourd'hui on a les premiers c'est
comme ça qu'ils le croient sans vous
poser la question de quelle
transformation de la société le problème
c'est qu'on a une addition de mesures on
peut dire saupoudrage et pas forcément
du saupoudrage cette addition de mesures
ne fait pas un projet on ne connaît pas
le projet de société des bains de macron
est ce qu'il veut c'est fait ils iront
c'est dans le contexte dans lequel ces
faits lyon sait sur quel mode horde et
s'est fêlé on sait avec quel électorat
il s'est fait élire mais depuis il a
mené une politique différente de ce
qu'il aurait dégénéré oui mais on a
protégé ses temps au tour il était plus
ouverte si ce n'est d'une société plus
protégés ce qui vu une société plus
égalitaire est ce qu'il ya une société
plus libre personne ne connaît le
catéchisme m'a simplement même tabac ont
filmé par emmanuel macron lui-même c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui a pas de
vision alors c'est pour ça que cette
campagne démarre par des mesures démarre
pas par un projet c'est peut-être un peu
les choses à l'envers parce qu'il faut
d'abord exprimer une vision et ensuite
les mesures viennent étoffer ce projet
est là pour l'instant on est plutôt dans
une démarche inverse une réponse
françois patriat puis ensuite on vient
la dette quand même parce que physique
comment va bien falloir bosser et
comment françois patriat non j'ai pas
d'élément de réponse et ce qui
effectivement c'est sur le manque de
vision quand même c'est ce que dit
matthieu croissandeau le problème de la
vision emmanuel bach on l'a nommé de
révolution à l'époque aujourd'hui alors
il est pour une société beaucoup plus
égalitaire plus performantes ou la
valeur travail existe le mieux plus
libérés plus libérée pendant tout parce
que je crois que dans ce pays et puis en
plus il ya des transformations affaires
jeunes par exemple moi je pense qu'il
faudra une nouvelle réforme des
collectivités territoriales peut pas
demander à un chef d'entreprise
aujourd'hui d'aller voir le maire la
commune le canton la chambre de commerce
la chambre des métiers le département la
région l'europe font pas bien changé ça
c'est des lourdeurs qu'il faut supprimer
ça on vous doit le faire maintenant
souvenez-vous des londres à l'époque on
doit le faire c'est une chose comme ça
deux qualifications une vision non mais
vous savez il quand j'étais ministre à
20 ans qui était déjà ministre
simplification mais j'en ai qu on en
fait beaucoup et les gens ne voient pas
que dans le même temps on fait la
nouvelle norme c'est d'accorder si oui
on empilait les nouvelles dont on arrive
c'est un peu compliqué on simplifie d'un
côté on empile de l'autre
emmanuel macron est en train de cramer
la caisse c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
valérie pécresse tiens on réécoute
xavier bertrand et valérie pécresse qui
concentre alors ils sont eux aussi en
campagne électorale mais qui concentre
les critiques sur le chef de l'état
parce qu'elle ce que nous voulons
aujourd'hui c'est faire gagner la droite
et nous pensons qu'il ya urgence pour le
pays parce que emmanuel macron qui a été
un président pour presque rien et qui
est en train de cramer la caisse arrête
son mandat en 2022 le quoi qu'il en
coûte pour les français il est fini le
quoi qu'il en coûte pour la réélection
des manuels macron il ne fait que
commencer emmanuel macron fait campagne
avec le chéquier de la france mais jean
alesi monsieur le journaliste pas de
votre joli métier
c'est le premier volet de droite
première priorité sanitaire maintenant
c'est de m'assurer que tous ses moyens
sur tout le territoire histoire
totalement utilisé une ue tu as vu ses
génériques table je sais depuis le début
si tu sais pas ça en étant prémices
offert une chose moi qui le film s'est
régulièrement depuis deux familles
[Musique]
en fait avoir par un éclat de rire ouais
moi rigoler
je suis
edwards homme de droite troisième
épisode aux manettes au samedi à 20h sur
public sénat
une rigueur québec est plus importante
le risque en fait qui est fille qu'est
ce qui nous dit bhl pour le public mais
c'est véritablement ça
il ya des normes à respecter
une rigueur budgétaire et que ba
bruxelles est là pour pour surveiller
dont bruxelles un moment va devoir
surveiller puis la bce elle va arrêter
aussi de financer et donc on va se
retrouver un peu seul face aux autres
pays européens avec des budgets a
présenté on devra véritablement cette
fois-ci annoncer des réformes et là les
français s'ils comprennent pas et s'ils
croient encore que le large au magic est
infinie parce qu'on est en train de m'en
faire croire ça le réveil social va être
brutal il y aura il ya un risque social
c'est qu'on n'a pas expliqué qu'aux
français au bout d'un moment il va
falloir que la facture soit payée allait
il nous reste un peu moins de cinq
minutes pour peut-être savoir où sont
les leviers d'économies pour un retour à
une forme de d'orthodoxie budgétaire je
me tourne vers vous jean-raymond humaine
et vous dites il faut baisser les
charges des entreprises serait bien mais
ça ça coûte de l'argent budget d'état
donc voir ce que vous trouvez des
économies ou mais écoutez vous reprenez
toutes les analyses tous les rapports
produits par le sénat chaque année
également de la chambre de la cour des
comptes oui et vous avez alors on
pourrait prendre le détail de même si
c'est une goutte d'eau dans le budget
mais pensez vous qu'aujourd'hui la
france ait besoin de quarante trois
ministres dont on ne connaît ni le nom
il
les responsabilités c'est une goutte
d'eau dans le budget non messieurs mais
vous prenez du bois gère la liste des
ministres nicolas sarkozy au début il
faut il en faut moins de vingt et une
parité à la fin y en a 40 c'est la
parité toujours la mer l'a40 s'esquisse
voyez par rapport aux petites phrases
valérie pécresse xavier bertand vous
avez oublié d'ailleurs un des candidats
et c'est le candidat que je soutiens
mais michel barnier ne dit pas du tout
sa nuit il veut faire gagner la france
avant de faire gagner un camp politique
c'est la france qui doit gagner tant que
c'est pas la france qui va être
rassemblée qui va se pose se penser
collectivement on ne peut pas en sortir
parce que les uns et les autres vont
faire l'autruche est ce qu a dit madame
est parfaitement juste
ce qui nous pend au nez ok mais elles
vont n'est pas tout à fait répondu à ma
question vous vous leviez d'économie
prioritaire c'est quoi les leviers
d'économies je voulais dire le pays
investit massivement massivement dans
des secteurs sur lequel il ne devrait
pas être aussi présent l'économie par
exemple parfait donc quelqu'un m'a
supprimé
free vient d'être mangé un
enchevêtrement de mesure chaque
gouvernement en remplaçant le sien et
puis il ya une mesure aussi parce que
agir c'est bien gentil mais la réforme
principale que ce pays doit accomplir on
passe à côté c'est la réforme des
retraites il faut mettre le pays à ce
moment-là pas à feu et à sang mais
autour de la table reconnaître des
professions qui sont des professions
particulièrement difficile qui ne
doivent pas être traités de la même
manière tant que cette réforme là ne
sera pas traité je peux vous garantir
qu'on aura des mains d'yves mathieu un
mot et françois patron parle bien de vos
différents muscles une autre escale
obligée de protection sociale et
l'obligé de settat même si on peut hein
dis oui j'ai
macroéconomique le premier poste
budgétaire l'état ce qu'elle aime la
charge de la dette et ensuite
/ and on and on pas non plus maintenant
à ineo est
ce les remboursements à la charge de la
dette est absolument pas un des budgets
qui pèse le plus actuellement sur le
budget le budget de l'état c'est quoi
c'est l'éducation
le remboursement a toujours été devant
devant le budget du ministère
d'éducation non non mais c'est vous
qui seraient
sinon c'est la masse salariale c'est sûr
et c'est essentiellement des grands
ministères et puis donc l éducation ou
un million de salariés quand même
premier second extrait est ce qu on veut
couper tailler dans les effectifs je
suis pas certain a précédé choix mais
les gros levier ils sont pas forcés je
me tourne vers les mers les économies
dernier motoko thomas dans les villes
les villes montrent tous poils à dijon
partout plus de policiers plus de moyens
pour la police et ils montrent des
policiers en plus quand on va plus
d'hôpitaux plus d'hôpitaux de proximité
et plus de maisons de retraite etc tous
les maires qui disent qu'ils ont l'école
le coni beefeater j'entends bien mais
ils ont tous leur investissement je
mentionné entre 50 et 75% par qui par
l'état ou par la région département donc
ils peuvent bien effectivement le faire
alors ensuite diminution moi la seule
dépense qui permettrait aujourd'hui
c'est le chômage c'est le chômage s'ils
ont fait diminuer le taux de chômage là
là on dépense vraiment les dépenses dans
l'état travers l'unedic alors là
vraiment dépenses vraiment alors le coup
des ministres permettait à une petite
plaisanterie les ministres entrent au
hockey mais lorsqu'on a voulu diminuer
le nombre de parlementaires députés et
sénateurs 30%
fondation nationale
et dj bas on peut pas lancer à nouveau
terrain j'ai mérité si à tous les
accusés d'avoir participé à ce débat
c'était passionnant mathieu vous et
c'est évidemment avec moi on passe un
autre chronique les électeurs ont la
parole